Do you remember where you were on April 10, 1999? What day of the week was it? What about the weather? What were you wearing? And what did you do all day? Chances are you can't answer any of those questions. For most of us, our autobiographical memory is a bit of a blur. Sure, some special occasions stand out, weddings, birthdays, vacations,
你还记得1999年4月10日你在哪里吗？那天是星期几？天气怎么样？你穿了什么？那一整天你都做了什么？你很可能回答不上来这些问题。对于我们大多数人来说，我们的自传体记忆有些模糊。当然，一些特殊的场合，比如婚礼、生日、假期，会让人印象深刻，
along with a bundle of random memories that stick with us for no special reason. But for people with highly superior autobiographical memory or H-SAM, every day is memorable. Ask someone with H-SAM what they were doing on April 10, 1999, or the 11th, or the 16th, and they'll be able to tell you, along with a bunch of other checkable facts. How do they do that? How do the brains of people with H-SAM store and retrieve this vast amount of detailed autobiographical information? What's it like to be able to remember every day of your life?
再加上一些因为某种原因而留在我们脑海中的零散记忆。但对于拥有“超强自传体记忆”（H-SAM）的人来说，每一天都是值得纪念的。问问拥有H-SAM的人1999年4月10日、11日或16日他们在做什么，他们不仅能告诉你，还能提供一堆其他可核实的事实。他们是怎么做到的？拥有H-SAM的人的大脑是如何存储和检索如此海量的详细自传体信息的？能够记住生命中的每一天是什么感觉？
Is it a blessing or a curse? And what can studying this unusual ability teach us about how memory works for the rest of us? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. We have two guests today. Dr. Michael Yasser is the director of the Center for the Neurobiology of Learning and Memory at the University of California, Irvine. The center was established in 1983 by Dr. James McGaugh,
这是一种福气还是一种诅咒？研究这种非凡的能力又能教会我们关于记忆如何为我们其他人运作的知识？欢迎收听《心理学谈话》，这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯。今天我们有两位嘉宾。迈克尔·亚萨博士是加州大学欧文分校学习与记忆神经生物学中心的主任。该中心由詹姆斯·麦高博士于1983年创立，
and it's where the first research on highly superior autobiographical memory began about 15 years ago. Today, Dr. Yassa and his colleagues continue to study H-SAM, along with how we learn and remember information, how learning and memory change with age, and how to better diagnose and treat disorders like Alzheimer's disease. Our second guest is Markey Pasternak, one of the few people in the world confirmed to have H-SAM. In 2014, when she was a junior in college, Ms. Pasternak learned about highly superior autobiographical memory in one of her psychology courses, realized that it described her special memory, and began participating in research at UC Irvine. She went on to earn a master's degree in education, and today works in student affairs at Auburn University, doing mental
大约15年前，关于超强自传体记忆的首次研究就是在这里开始的。今天，亚萨博士和他的同事们继续研究H-SAM，以及我们如何学习和记忆信息、学习和记忆如何随年龄增长而变化，以及如何更好地诊断和治疗阿尔茨海默病等疾病。我们的第二位嘉宾是马基·帕斯捷尔纳克，她是世界上极少数被证实拥有H-SAM的人之一。2014年，当她还是大学三年级学生时，帕斯捷尔纳克女士在一门心理学课程中了解到了超强自传体记忆，意识到这描述的就是她特殊的记忆力，并开始参与加州大学欧文分校的研究。她后来获得了教育学硕士学位，目前在奥本大学的学生事务部门工作，从事心理
wellness and health education outreach. She also blogs and speaks to the media about living with H-SAM. Thank you both for joining us today. Thank you for having me. Yes, thank you so much for having us. Dr. Yasser, you get the first questions. When people with H-Sam retrieve autobiographical memories, are they doing the same thing that most of us do when we remember our past, but they're just much better at it than the rest of us? You know, you started with a very difficult question, Kim. I think this is really what we're trying to get to the bottom of. And part of the problem is that when we were first kind of exposed to this phenomenon, it violated all of our assumptions about how memory works. So one of the first thoughts was, well, they must be using a different mechanism.
健康和健康教育推广工作。她还撰写博客，并向媒体讲述与H-SAM共处的生活。感谢你们两位今天加入我们。谢谢邀请我。是的，非常感谢邀请我们。亚萨博士，第一个问题问您。当拥有H-SAM的人检索自传体记忆时，他们做的事情和我们大多数人回忆过去时做的事情是一样的，只是他们比我们其他人做得好得多吗？你知道，你问了一个非常困难的问题，金。我认为这正是我们试图弄清楚的。问题的一部分在于，当我们最初接触到这种现象时，它违背了我们关于记忆如何运作的所有假设。所以最初的想法之一是，好吧，他们一定使用了不同的机制。
But push to the extreme, one can imagine that our regular memory systems just have a degree of variation in them, that it could be part of the regular mechanisms, just like I said, pushed to the extreme. And we're still not sure if they're part of it. that natural variation or if they're using very distinct mechanisms and that's what we're hoping to uncover in the coming years with some brain imaging techniques and various other methods that look deep into the neurobiology of the brain. Markey, can you talk about how this works for you? When you remember a particular day from 10 years ago, what are you doing? Does the memory just pop up or do you have to work to retrieve it? So it kind of depends on the day. I was actually talking to a
但推向极端，人们可以想象我们的常规记忆系统只是存在一定程度的差异，它可能是常规机制的一部分，就像我说的，推向了极端。我们仍然不确定他们是否属于那种自然变异，还是他们使用了非常独特的机制，这正是我们希望在未来几年通过一些脑成像技术和各种其他深入观察大脑神经生物学的方法来揭示的。马基，你能谈谈这对你来说是如何运作的吗？当你回忆起10年前的某一天时，你在做什么？记忆是自动跳出来的，还是你必须努力去检索它？这有点取决于具体是哪一天。其实大约一年前，我曾和奥本大学的一位
psychology professor at Auburn about this about a year ago because it's fun working at universities, right? Because the psychology departments get real excited. And what I told him is I, and we kind of coined them, I have these things called go-to dates, right? Dates that just stick in my memory because of an event that happened that maybe had more of an emotional connection to it. So for example, I know like sad example to start off with, but if you ask me the day my father died, right, I'd be like March 16th, 2014, and most people could probably do that. But then I also can remember, you know, the day I saw a boy I had a crush on in the seventh grade for the first time in a while. And that was June 26, 2007. It was a Tuesday. And I could tell you all about that, right? So like they can get,
心理学教授谈过这个问题，因为在大学工作很有趣，对吧？因为心理学系的人会非常兴奋。我告诉他的是，我们给它们起了一个名字，我有一些所谓的“首选日期”，对吧？那些因为发生了一些可能带有更多情感联系的事件而留在我的记忆中的日期。所以举个例子，我知道这是一个悲伤的例子，但如果你问我我父亲去世的那一天，对吧，我会说是2014年3月16日，大多数人可能都能做到这一点。但我也能记得，你知道，我第一次见到我在七年级时暗恋的那个男孩的那一天。那是2007年6月26日。那是一个星期二。我可以告诉你关于那天的所有事情，对吧？所以就像他们可以得到，
you have more random days that you hold with these things. But, you know, if I can go real back to, let's say go to that 2007 date, right? If I can go back and say, yeah, I saw this guy, you know, at the ice rink because I was a figure skater and he was a hockey player and I like bumped into him there and I can tell you all about that. I can also piece around the days around it and that's where the memory kind of starts coming into fruition. And so I can say, oh, I went to that ice skating practice that day, even though I didn't usually skate on Tuesday nights over the summer because I had stayed with another friend on my figure skating team that day. And it was her birthday in a couple days. And so I was spending time with her because it had just been a birthday party the day before. So I can
你有更多随机的日子，你用这些东西来保存。但是，你知道，如果我可以回到，比如说回到2007年的那个日期，对吧？如果我可以回去说，是的，我在溜冰场看到了这个家伙，因为我是一名花样滑冰运动员，他是曲棍球运动员，我在那里碰到了他，我可以告诉你关于那天的所有事情。我也可以拼凑出那几天周围的事情，这就是记忆开始实现的地方。所以我可以说，哦，那天我去参加了花样滑冰练习，尽管我通常夏天周二晚上不去滑冰，因为那天我和花样滑冰队的另一个朋友待在一起。再过几天就是她的生日了。所以我当时和她在一起，因为前一天刚举行过生日派对。所以我可以
like that context kind of comes in and I can start piecing around it. So sometimes if you ask me like a date, I might be like, oh wait, I don't know exactly what I did on that day quite yet, but I can go to my nearest go to date, put the context together and kind of crawl to it. And it's like a mental image for me. And I know this is different between different people with H. Sam. I know I've talked to some friends with H Sam, who say they just picture like a calendar, like a black and white regular calendar. That's not me. I have some synesthesia as well. So for me, what it looks like is it's like a giant like candy land board sort of a thing I think of it or like a giant map or like a road with a journey. It's all different colors and there's dates everywhere and there's like people and images and
那种背景就会浮现出来，我可以开始拼凑周围的事情。所以有时如果你问我一个日期，我可能会说，哦等等，我还不完全知道那天我做了什么，但我可以去我最近的“首选日期”，把背景拼凑起来，然后慢慢摸索到它。对我来说，这就像一幅心理图像。我知道这在不同的H-SAM患者之间是不同的。我知道我和一些有H-SAM的朋友谈过，他们说他们只是想象一个日历，就像一个黑白的普通日历。我不是这样。我也有一些联觉。所以对我来说，它看起来像是一个巨大的糖果乐园棋盘之类的东西，或者像一张巨大的地图，或者像一条有旅程的道路。到处都是不同的颜色，到处都是日期，还有人、图像和
places. And it's like this fun place in my brain I can kind of go to and like hop around of different days and I can like zoom in on the days and the years and all in the times and all that stuff. That sounds amazing. Well, Markey, when did you first realize that your memory was different from that of other people? How old were you? And what triggered that realization? Yeah. So I'm going to be honest. I feel like sometimes when I answer this question, I feel like it's supposed to be an aha moment, right? Like this big like, oh my gosh, my brain's different. But the reality is, is that it was just a series of little moments. that added to the realization over a lot of years because it's so unique and kind of difficult
地方。这就像我大脑中一个有趣的地方，我可以去那里，在不同的日子之间跳来跳去，我可以放大日子、年份、时间等等。这听起来太神奇了。那么，马基，你是什么时候第一次意识到你的记忆力与其他人不同的？你多大了？是什么触发了这种认识？是的，说实话。我觉得有时当我回答这个问题时，我觉得它应该是一个“顿悟时刻”，对吧？就像那种巨大的“天哪，我的大脑与众不同”。但现实是，这只是一系列小瞬间，
to figure out, especially when it's happening to you as a kid, you know, and you don't really have all the vocabulary to describe what's going on. And so the first time I noticed it was different was probably in 2006. I was, I had just turned 12 years old. And I started realizing I could remember what I was doing a year ago every day. Like I was like, oh, it's, you know, May 11th. Like, year ago was our band concert and then we left for Florida the next day but like no one else really cared to remember that our band concert was a year ago that day but for some reason I just knew and like I remember being like I should check like what's happening I should check this out so I went to the home video and there it was like you know May 11th 2005 and I was like okay you know and so I started
在很多年里积累成了这种认识，因为它太独特了，而且有点难以弄清楚，尤其是当你还是个孩子的时候，你知道，你并没有所有的词汇来描述正在发生的事情。所以我第一次注意到它与众不同可能是在2006年。我当时刚满12岁。我开始意识到我能记住一年前每一天我在做什么。就像我当时想，哦，你知道，5月11日。一年前那天是我们的乐队音乐会，然后第二天我们就出发去佛罗里达了，但没有其他人真的在意去记住那天是乐队音乐会一周年，但出于某种原因我就是知道，我记得当时想，我应该核实一下，看看发生了什么，我应该查一下。所以我看了家庭录像，它就在那里，你知道，2005年5月11日，我就想，好吧，你知道，所以我开始
realizing it then and then as the years went on I I realized I could keep doing it. Like, it wasn't just, I had a good memory for 2005, 2006 stuck, 2007 stuck, 2008 stuck. And so when I was in eighth grade, I really got obsessed with like memories and old pictures and dates and things like that. And it was just becoming something that was kind of crystallizing in my brain more. And I realized that the first like week I could remember was the week of February 9th through the 13th of 2015. And the ninth was a Wednesday. And everything just kind of starts on that Wednesday.
在那时意识到这一点，然后随着岁月的流逝，我意识到我可以一直这样做。就像，不仅仅是我对2005年有很好的记忆，2006年也记住了，2007年记住了，2008年记住了。所以当我在八年级时，我真的沉迷于记忆、旧照片、日期之类的事情。它正在成为我大脑中某种结晶的东西。我意识到我能记住的第一周是2015年2月9日到13日的那一周。9号是星期三。一切都从那个星期三开始。
And then the next days are real vivid. And then like the next week or two is kind of blurry. But then after that, everything is really vivid. And I was like, you know, do I have those dates right? And so I remember I was ahead of figure skating competition as I was talking about figure skating earlier that weekend in a place called Beaver Dam, Wisconsin. Or is my father like to call it Beaver Darn? And I went in the.
然后接下来的几天非常生动。然后接下来的那一两周有点模糊。但那之后，一切都非常生动。我就想，你知道，我那些日期记对了吗？所以我记得那天周末我有一场花样滑冰比赛，就像我之前提到的，在威斯康星州一个叫比弗达姆的地方。或者像我父亲喜欢叫它“比弗达恩”的地方。我去了
basement and I dug through like my mom's like totes of like old memorabilia and scrapbooking stuff. And I found the brochure from that competition. And it said February 13th, 2005. And I was like, all right. I have something here. So that was kind of the realization of it is a kid. Wow. There are 7.9 billion people in the world today, give or take a few thousand. Dr. Yassa, how many people have been confirmed to have H. Sam? And how do you find these people? Another tricky question, Kim. So I'll give you the answer that we have, but there's a caveat, right? So we have identified, it's smaller than 100 that we have identified in the laboratory.
地下室，翻找我妈妈装旧纪念品和剪贴簿的箱子。我找到了那场比赛的宣传册。上面写着2005年2月13日。我就想，好吧。我确实有这个能力。所以这就是作为一个孩子对它的认识。哇。今天世界上有79亿人，上下浮动几千人。亚萨博士，有多少人被证实拥有H-SAM？你们是如何找到这些人的？又是一个棘手的问题，金。所以我给你我们掌握的答案，但有一个警告，对吧？所以我们已经确定了，我们在实验室中确定的不到100人。
But we are also getting reports from our colleagues actually around the world in different countries of also having individuals kind of come to them and say, I have this extremely vivid memory in the past. and they may not have seen a 60 minutes piece or read about it in a book or a paper, but just sort of think it's curious. But that's really the issue is that until maybe Markey has gone for this exercise and really confirmed it or somebody has seen a piece on 60 minutes or read a paper or heard about it in a class, it's really difficult to see this as something different from everybody else.
但我们也从世界各地不同国家的同事那里收到报告，说也有人来找他们说，我过去有这种极其生动的记忆。他们可能没有看过《60分钟》的报道，也没有在书或论文中读到过它，只是觉得这很奇怪。但这确实是问题所在，直到马基可能经历了这种练习并真正证实了它，或者有人看过《60分钟》的片段，或者读过论文，或者在课堂上听说过，否则真的很难将其视为与其他人不同的东西。
So my guess is that actually there's a lot of people. people out there that have it and just don't know and have no reason to suspect that it's all that different. They may just be on the extreme. They might think of themselves as having really good memory, but they may not think of it as a unique condition. And they might look at others around them and think, well, why does everybody else have really crappy memory? You know, as opposed to them sort of being the unique ones. So I think we're probably underestimating the number of folks who have it. I don't think it's limited to 100. I think it's more likely to be in the thousands, which still makes it a unique enough condition. But we have to have a better
所以我猜实际上有很多人拥有这种能力，只是不知道，也没有理由怀疑它有什么不同。他们可能只是处于极端。他们可能认为自己记忆力很好，但他们可能不认为这是一种独特的状况。他们可能会看着周围的人，心想，为什么其他人的记忆力这么差？你知道，而不是认为自己是独特的那一个。所以我认为我们可能低估了拥有它的人数。我不认为它仅限于100人。我认为更有可能是数千人，这仍然使它成为一种足够独特的状况。但我们必须有更好的
means to get those numbers. What are the tests like when you're trying to confirm that somebody actually has it? Yeah, so you've gone through this already, Marky. And here's the problem with the tests, is that the initial phase of the testing was really based on sort of almanac-type knowledge. Let's pick on something that can have a veridical record that could be confirmed. So public events, things that, you know, it's very clear what the actual answers are. But it turned out as we, and we were able to identify a lot of people that way. But it turned out as time went on, you recognize that there are folks who just this may not be their area of expertise. They may not be very attuned to celebrities in particular, you know, public events, but they have incredibly good autobiographical memory.
方法来获得这些数字。当你试图确认某人是否真的拥有这种能力时，测试是什么样的？是的，马基，你已经经历过这个了。测试的问题在于，测试的初始阶段确实是基于某种年鉴式的知识。让我们挑选一些可以有真实记录并能被证实的东西。所以公共事件，你知道，实际答案非常清楚的事情。但事实证明，随着我们能够通过这种方式识别出很多人，但随着时间的推移，你意识到有些人可能这并不是他们的专业领域。他们可能对名人特别不关注，你知道，公共事件，但他们有令人难以置信的自传体记忆。
So how do you derive a test that is sensitive to those variations and expertise? And in fact, that's work that's ongoing in our lab right now. We're trying to devise a more individualized approach that takes the categories of expertise of the individual and then selects the questions for the tool based on the areas that they have selected in a pre-test to say those are the things I'm comfortable with. Those are the areas where I think I have a lot of knowledge that are related to my autobiography. I was a big TV buff when I was growing up. I love sports.
那么你如何设计一个对这些差异和专业知识敏感的测试呢？事实上，这是我们实验室目前正在进行的工作。我们正在尝试设计一种更个性化的方法，它采用个人的专业知识类别，然后根据他们在预测试中选择的领域来为工具选择问题，说这些是我感到舒适的事情。这些是我认为我有很多与我的自传相关的知识的领域。我成长过程中是一个电视迷。我喜欢体育。
you know, whatever it may be. And then we can be a little bit more sensitive to their special abilities in those kinds of domains. Do people with H-SAM have above-average memories in general, like for facts and figures and non-autobiographical knowledge? That's the part that's really, really interesting. Not at all. So it really is just autobiographical. I know, Marky's making that expression that suggests that you wish it was better for everything else. And I think that's the reaction we hear from most people.
无论它可能是什么。然后我们可以对他们在这些领域中的特殊能力更加敏感。拥有H-SAM的人在一般情况下是否有高于平均水平的记忆力，比如事实、数字和非自传体知识？这部分真的非常非常有趣。完全没有。所以它确实只是自传体的。我知道，马基做出的那个表情表明你希望它在其他方面也更好。我认为这是我们从大多数人那里听到的反应。
You know, they weren't maybe all that exceptional in terms of their school. It's not like they could memorize all Shakespeare and all of these things. You know, their memorization is really just average. And if you test them on standardized memory tests, you know, word list recall and things like that, it's really just average. It seems to be highly specialized for the person's own narrative, for their own autobiographical memories and events, things that have happened to them. and other things that are related to that narrative. So if, say, you're studying French in school and you have H-SAM, does that mean that you're going to have better memory for vocabulary and verb conjugations, for example?
你知道，他们在学校方面可能并不那么出色。并不是说他们能背诵所有的莎士比亚作品和所有这些东西。你知道，他们的记忆力确实只是平均水平。如果你对他们进行标准化的记忆测试，你知道，单词列表回忆之类的，它确实只是平均水平。它似乎是高度专门针对个人自己的叙述，针对他们自己的自传体记忆和事件，发生在他们身上的事情，以及与该叙述相关的其他事情。所以，如果你在学校学习法语，并且拥有H-SAM，这是否意味着你对词汇和动词变位会有更好的记忆，例如？
Not at all, unless you can figure out a way to make French really be part of your autobiographical narrative. So if you've traveled to France and spend time there, it became sort of part of your background and autobiography that I think, that that's a possibility. But just naturally taking it in class, I think the reaction is the same one that you get from everybody else. I'm not going to remember much until I practice it. Markey, what was it like to take the test to confirm that you actually have this? I love this question because not a lot of people ask it. So that's what's cool about being on this podcast in particular. You know, I was nervous. I was really nervous because for me, the stake
完全不会，除非你能想出一种方法让法语真正成为你自传叙述的一部分。所以如果你去过法国并在那里待过，它成为了你背景和自传的一部分，我认为，那是有可能的。但只是自然地在课堂上学习它，我认为反应和你从其他人那里得到的一样。除非我练习，否则我记不住多少。马基，参加测试以确认你真的拥有这种能力是什么感觉？我喜欢这个问题，因为没有多少人问它。所以这就是这个播客特别酷的地方。你知道，我很紧张。我真的很紧张，因为对我来说，赌注
for high. The stakes for me taking this test were if I don't, if they asked dates and events that I don't get right, I'm going to be excluded from this group of people that I know I belong to. And that could give me some sort of solidarity in a community where I feel isolated in a lot of the world because of my memory. So I was really nervous, you know. And so I was a junior in college at Marquette University. I had just learned the previous semester about H. Sam in a class, like you had said in the introduction. And my professor was confident I had it. Like she was a neuroscientist and a neuroscience professor studying Alzheimer's opposite of what was going on with me. And she, you know, she knew a lot. She had done her postdoc at UC Irvine and knew a lot of the folks over there and was like,
很高。我参加这个测试的赌注是，如果我答不对他们问的日期和事件，我就会被排除在这个我知道我属于的群体之外。这可能会让我在一个因为我的记忆而在世界上感到孤立的社区中获得某种团结感。所以我真的很紧张，你知道。所以当时我在马凯特大学读大三。就像你在介绍中所说的那样，我在上一学期的一门课上刚了解到H-SAM。我的教授确信我有这种能力。她是一位神经科学家，也是一位研究阿尔茨海默病的神经科学教授，这与我身上发生的事情正好相反。而且她，你知道，她知道很多。她在加州大学欧文分校做过博士后，认识那边很多研究人员，就说，
you, you have. These are the people you need to talk to. Yes, exactly. And so, um, I did the test over the phone. And I believe my first test was on March 1st of 2015. And what had happened was my friends actually helped me like kind of practice a little bit. So what they did was they would throw me like for the week before like current events randomly. I'd be like studying for a test. And they'd be like, when was the Sandy Hook shooting? I'd be like December 14th, 2012.
你，你有。这些人是你需要交谈的对象。是的，完全正确。所以，嗯，我通过电话进行了测试。我相信我的第一次测试是在2015年3月1日。发生的事情是我的朋友们实际上帮我练习了一点。所以他们做的是，在测试前的一周里，他们会随机给我抛出时事。我当时正在为考试学习。他们会问，桑迪胡克小学枪击案是什么时候？我会说2012年12月14日。
And like, you know, just so I'd get my brain. in that mode of like I can do it quick because I can do it if you allow me enough time, but I didn't know how long these researchers were willing to give me to answer the questions. And so I had some nice collaborative roommates and friends on campus who are like, we know you have this, we're going to help you, we got this, you know. And the test ended up going well. But to kind of jump on what Dr. Yasa was saying as well is that it's a really difficult thing to test because I was one of the youngest people they had ever tested at the time back in
就像，你知道，只是为了让我的大脑进入那种模式，我可以快速做到，因为如果你给我足够的时间，我可以做到，但我不知道这些研究人员愿意给我多长时间来回答问题。所以我有一些很好的合作室友和校园里的朋友，他们说，我们知道你有这个能力，我们会帮你的，我们搞得定，你知道。测试结果最终很好。但要接着亚萨博士所说的，这是一个非常难测试的事情，因为我是当时他们测试过的最年轻的人之一，回到
2015. So they were asking a lot of questions that were not relevant to me and they were not in my time frame. So they asked me, you know, gosh, I'm just trying to think, you know, when the Oscars were in 97, I didn't know that because I was three years old and I did not care about the Oscars. But I didn't want that to be a point against me. So they had to like ask me, you know, different questions. And I think that's the another hard part about testing h sam is that you've got these age groups who can remember different things at different times so it's not only the interests but it's it's the ages because even if i can remember in 2005 and there's like a political event that took place a fifth grader doesn't care um and probably if i was you know i was privileged enough to probably not even have to care at the time
2015年。所以他们问了很多与我不相关的问题，而且不在我的时间范围内。所以他们问我，天哪，我只是在想，你知道，97年的奥斯卡颁奖典礼是什么时候，我不知道，因为我当时才三岁，我根本不在乎奥斯卡。但我不想让那成为扣分项。所以他们不得不问我，你知道，不同的问题。我认为这是测试H-SAM的另一个难点，因为你有这些年龄组，他们可以在不同时间记住不同的事情，所以不仅是兴趣，还有年龄，因为即使我能记住2005年，如果发生了一件政治事件，五年级学生并不关心，而且如果我当时，你知道，我有幸可能当时甚至不需要关心，
if it didn't affect my population and so uh that can be i think really difficult too and that's what it into in the testing a lot was like there are just some events that they had asked that were in my timeframe but I didn't hear about you know in sixth grade but they were able to do some replacements it sounds a little bit like you were studying to go on jeopardy yeah a little bit a little bit but just like again getting my brain in that mode because I knew I could do it I wasn't like memorizing dates or anything it was just kind of getting in that like recall mode where I could go kind of fast with it. So there was that, you know. Dr. Yasser, what do we know about the causes of H-SAM? Is there a genetic component to it or any other hints about the etiology?
如果它没有影响到我的群体，所以，嗯，我认为这也会非常困难，这就是测试中很多内容，就像他们问的一些事件确实在我的时间范围内，但我并没有听说过，你知道，在六年级时，但他们能够做一些替换。听起来有点像你在为参加《危险边缘》节目做准备。是的，有点，有点，但就像再次让我的大脑进入那种模式，因为我知道我能做到，我不是在死记硬背日期什么的，这只是进入那种回忆模式，我可以很快地回忆起来。所以有那个，你知道。亚萨博士，我们对H-SAM的成因了解多少？它有遗传成分吗，或者关于病因学的任何其他线索？
Yeah. So we're trying to get to the bottom of the potential heritability. So we don't think it's a direct genetic component as in if somebody has it, they're going to pass it on to their children. But interestingly, in some of the cases, it turns out that there's also kind of extended family, relatives, cousins, maybe who have some traces of it as well. So it's a complex heritability pattern, if there is one. And we're working with some colleagues who are really exceptional in terms of working on genetics to try to reveal the basis of this. Interestingly, one thing that might give us some clues is a set of identical twins. and one of them has it, the other one does not. So it automatically tells us that it cannot be genetically inherited directly
是的。所以我们正在试图弄清楚潜在的遗传性。所以我们认为它不是一种直接的遗传成分，即如果某人拥有它，他们就会把它传给他们的孩子。但有趣的是，在某些案例中，事实证明还有某种大家庭，亲戚，表亲，可能也有一些它的痕迹。所以如果存在的话，这是一个复杂的遗传模式。我们正在与一些在遗传学方面非常出色的同事合作，试图揭示其基础。有趣的是，可能给我们一些线索的一件事是一对同卵双胞胎，其中一个拥有它，另一个没有。所以它自动告诉我们它不能直接遗传，
because otherwise they would share that. But there may be something that happens after the original splitting of that DNA that might be different. And we're trying to get to the bottom of that. But it is complicated because we don't have a huge sample to test. And certainly even within that smaller sample, the number of folks where there might be a trace of heritability is even smaller. So it's not entirely clear how much of it is heritable and how much of it is environmental.
否则他们会共享它。但在DNA最初分裂后可能发生了一些不同的事情。我们正在试图弄清楚这一点。但这很复杂，因为我们没有一个巨大的样本来测试。当然，即使在那个较小的样本中，可能存在遗传痕迹的人数甚至更少。所以它在多大程度上是可遗传的，在多大程度上是环境因素，并不完全清楚。
With respect to how the onset, it does vary from individual to individual. Usually there's sort of a precipitating period or event. Usually it's during adolescence where that kind of comes fully to fruition. And it may be sort of the first person's first realization that this is what's going on. Or it may be that memories start to get really, really strong after a particular event that could be a big change. It's possible that it's traumatic. It's possible that it's just kind of a big event that happened in the person's life that is highly salient, consequential, maybe a move or something like that. And then typically folks would report that from that point onwards, they've had these experiences kind of be sealed more into their memories.
关于发病，它确实因人而异。通常有一个沉淀期或事件。通常是在青春期，这种能力才完全实现。这可能是某人第一次意识到正在发生的事情。或者可能是记忆在特定事件之后变得非常非常强烈，这可能是一个巨大的变化。它可能是创伤性的。它可能只是发生在个人生活中具有高度显著性、后果性的重大事件，也许是搬家之类的。然后通常人们会报告说，从那时起，他们就有了这些体验，这些体验更深入地封存在了他们的记忆中。
So, Markey, are you aware of any relatives you have who also have H-SAM? No, but at Marquette, when I was working with Dr. Nielsen in their psychology department, she asked a lot of questions about my parents and actually brought my mom in to do some cognitive testing in an interview. And what we found is that my mom is really good with like verbal recall and she's also good at, she has a very strong autobiographical memory, not as strong. as mine, like remembering certain dates. But if you ask her, she could tell you about events, where we sat when we were at this concert or, you know, what was going on in our family last
那么，马基，你知道你有任何亲戚也拥有H-SAM吗？没有，但在马凯特大学，当我和心理学系的尼尔森博士一起工作时，她问了很多关于我父母的问题，实际上还请我妈妈来做了一些认知测试和访谈。我们发现我妈妈在语言回忆方面非常出色，而且她也很擅长，她有非常强大的自传体记忆，没有我那么强，比如记住特定的日期。但如果你问她，她可以告诉你关于事件的事情，我们在那场音乐会上坐在哪里，或者，你知道，我们家去年发生了什么
Christmas or, you know, whatever it was. My dad was already passed away by the time that we realized I had H. Sam and there was a name to call it. And so he died the same year I found out I had H. Sam, so a couple months before. But what we remember about my father is he had an incredible ability to remember numbers. He had, he knew people's addresses from his childhood, people's phone numbers from his childhood that he didn't need anymore. He had our whole family's social security numbers memorized, you know, that he could just say. And so, you know, he had that. And then my mom had the memory thing. So it's kind of interesting how for me those kind of combined in like a memorization of numbers or an ability to remember
圣诞节，或者，你知道，无论是什么。在我意识到我拥有H-SAM并且有一个名字可以称呼它时，我父亲已经去世了，所以是在我发现我有H-SAM的那一年去世的，所以是在几个月前。但我们关于我父亲的记忆是他有一种令人难以置信的记忆数字的能力。他有，他记得他童年时的地址，他童年时不再需要的电话号码。他背下了我们全家人的社会安全号码，你知道，他随口就能说出来。所以，你知道，他有那个。然后我妈妈有那个记忆力。所以对我来说，这些结合在一起，比如数字的记忆或记住数字的能力，比如日期，以及自传体部分，这很有趣。
numbers like dates and then also the autobiographical part of it as well. I understand there are some links between H-SAM and some mental health conditions. Marky, you've written about the connection between your H-SAM and obsessive-compulsive disorder. Can you talk about that? Okay, yeah. So I really feel like my H-SAM and OCD are pretty heavily linked. And it's because anytime after I got diagnosed with OCD, people would be like, what are you obsessed with? What are you obsessed with? And I honestly didn't know. I was just like, I have compulsions and I feel like I have to do things and I have a lot of anxiety and I have a tendency to hoard things, you know, all things I've been treated for and whatnot. But then as I started working with my, you know, with H-Sam and stuff, I realized
我知道H-SAM和一些心理健康状况之间存在一些联系。马基，你写过关于你的H-SAM和强迫症（OCD）之间联系的文章。你能谈谈吗？好的，是的。所以我真的觉得我的H-SAM和强迫症联系非常紧密。这是因为在我被诊断出患有强迫症后的任何时候，人们都会问，你沉迷于什么？你沉迷于什么？我真的不知道。我只是说，我有强迫行为，我觉得我必须做一些事情，我有很大的焦虑，我有囤积东西的倾向，你知道，所有这些我都接受过治疗等等。但后来当我开始处理我的H-SAM等事情时，我意识到
my obsession was dates, dates and calendars and my own events in my life. Because, you know, what, kind of helped me do, or not help me do, but it helped the OCD flourish in a lot of ways when I was younger because I could remember exactly how something happened and then I'd create a ritual to reinforce it. So what would happen was let's say I wore a particular shirt the day I was taking a math test I was really nervous about. Because of my memory, I could remember, you know, everything I did that day, the shirt I wore, what I ate for breakfast, you know, who I talked to that day. And then the part of my brain that was responsible for my OCD would be like, all right, well, next time you've got a math test, if you want to get an A, guess who you have to talk to. Guess what you have to eat for breakfast. Guess what you have to wear? And it started reinforcing that. So I think my memory played a large role into creating a lot of rituals that I was kind of slave to for a long, long time. Dr. Yes. Is that common among the people you work with?
我的痴迷是日期、日历和我自己生活中的事件。因为，你知道，什么，帮助我做，或者不是帮助我做，但它在很多方面帮助强迫症在年轻时蓬勃发展，因为我可以准确地记住某事是如何发生的，然后我会创造一个仪式来强化它。所以会发生的是，假设我在参加一场我非常紧张的数学考试那天穿了一件特定的衬衫。因为我的记忆力，我可以记住，你知道，那天我做的每一件事，我穿的衬衫，我早餐吃了什么，你知道，那天我和谁谈过话。然后我大脑中负责强迫症的部分就会说，好吧，下次你有数学考试时，如果你想得A，猜猜你必须和谁谈话。猜猜你早餐必须吃什么。猜猜你必须穿什么？它开始强化这一点。所以我认为我的记忆在创造我长期以来一直受其奴役的许多仪式中发挥了重要作用。亚萨博士，这在你共事的人中常见吗？
Absolutely. So we see elements of this, perhaps maybe not at the level of a full diagnosis of obsessive compulsive disorder, but certainly obsessive tendencies and obsessions, so the thoughts themselves. That seems to be much more highly represented in the group with H. Sam. And, you know, it's interesting actually for me really to hear Markey speak about it because we've struggled to try to understand the causality chain. In other words, is it that those two are sort of co-occurring conditions and they're sort of feeding off of one another and some individuals maybe to an extent but not others or is one actually leading to the other? In other words, if there's evidence of obsessions that are related to dates, if that happens in any individual who might otherwise be, you know, perfectly fine, does it lead to this HCM condition? And we don't know the answer to that. I don't know if it's going to be that simple or straightforward, to be honest with you. I do think that there are some interesting shared traits and shared mechanisms,
绝对常见。所以我们看到了这些元素，也许可能没有达到强迫症的全面诊断水平，但肯定有强迫倾向和强迫观念，即思想本身。这似乎在H-SAM群体中表现得更为突出。而且，你知道，听到马基谈论它对我来说真的很有趣，因为我们一直在努力理解因果链。换句话说，是这两种情况是共存的，它们在某种程度上相互滋养，在某些个体中可能达到一定程度，但在其他人中则不然，还是其中一种实际上导致了另一种？换句话说，如果有与日期相关的强迫观念的证据，如果这发生在任何可能本来完全正常的人身上，它会导致这种H-SAM状况吗？我们不知道这个问题的答案。老实说，我不知道它是否会那么简单或直接。我确实认为有一些有趣的共同特征和共同机制，
especially as Markey was talking about, obsessing over dates, and they become much more important, much more consequential, because you see the value. That kind of feed-forward cycle can precipitate the condition, can perhaps lead to higher levels of anxiety and higher levels of anxiety and higher levels of OCD, but also can make the H-SAM abilities much more reinforceable. So if you're practicing this often and thinking about it often, you can imagine, just like anything else, you're going to get better at it.
特别是正如马基所谈到的，沉迷于日期，它们变得更加重要，更加具有后果性，因为你看到了价值。那种前馈循环可以促成这种状况，可能导致更高水平的焦虑和更高水平的强迫症，但也可以使H-SAM能力更容易被强化。所以如果你经常练习这个并经常思考它，你可以想象，就像其他任何事情一样，你会变得更擅长它。
One thing that Marky mentioned earlier, which I love because I've heard it now from a number of our volunteers, is the notion of going back a year. So saying, you know, today is April 16th. What happened on April 16th, 2020? What about 2019? What about 2018? And we'll often hear that, and it seems like, you know, kind of a strange thing maybe, but it is an archival mechanism.
马基之前提到的有一件事，我非常喜欢，因为我现在已经从我们的许多志愿者那里听到了，那就是回到一年前的概念。所以说，你知道，今天是4月16日。2020年4月16日发生了什么？2019年呢？2018年呢？我们经常听到这个，它看起来，你知道，可能是一件奇怪的事情，但它是一种档案机制。
It's a way to kind of build a record of the past day by day. So we're still trying to figure out what those organizational schemes might look like, but I'm fascinated that this game of going back a year is actually something that was commonly shared across a number of volunteers that we've spoken to. You were both quoted in a Wall Street Journal article last summer about how the COVID-Lock were affecting people's memory. And as you talked about this, going back a year, going back a year and going back a year, what has the lockdown done to the memories of people with H. Sam?
这是一种逐日建立过去记录的方法。所以我们仍在试图弄清楚这些组织方案可能是什么样子，但我很着迷于这种回到一年前的游戏实际上是我们交谈过的许多志愿者共同分享的事情。去年夏天，你们俩都在《华尔街日报》的一篇文章中被引用，谈论封锁是如何影响人们的记忆的。当你们谈论这个时，回到一年前，回到一年前，回到一年前，封锁对H-SAM患者的记忆有什么影响？
So if you're directing this at me, I can tell you just in generalities. And what we have heard from some of our volunteers is that they don't feel that their track record, their memory of the past is as good as it was. because there's not enough events and not enough things happening, not enough salient dates with real occurrences to be able to gravitate to. But we've heard the same thing also from everybody else. So I don't think it's just limited to H-SAM. I think it really is kind of almost like a memory fog that we're all experiencing
所以如果你是在问我，我可以告诉你一些概括性的情况。我们从一些志愿者那里听到的是，他们觉得他们的记录，他们对过去的记忆不如以前好了。因为没有足够的事件，没有足够的事情发生，没有足够的带有真实发生的显著日期来吸引他们。但我们也从其他人那里听到了同样的事情。所以我认为这不仅仅局限于H-SAM。我认为这确实几乎就像我们所有人都在经历的一种记忆迷雾，
because it has been so monotonous and we've all been stuck at home and locked down. There hasn't been enough experiences with novelty in them that our memory system it's kind of gravity to say, this is important. I need to store that for later use. But I'd love to hear from Marky what her feelings have been also. Yeah, I would too. Is it disconcerting that you don't have these hooks to grab onto? Yeah, and I've really found it's just a portion of lockdown.
因为它太单调了，我们都被困在家里，被封锁了。没有足够的新奇体验，以至于我们的记忆系统无法说，这很重要。我需要存储它以供以后使用。但我很想听听马基的感受。是的，我也想听听。没有这些钩子可以抓住，这是否令人不安？是的，我真的发现这只是封锁的一部分。
And maybe it's because I live in Alabama, so it looks a little different here. But, you know, last March is really vivid. Last March when, you know, I remember like, you know, everything shutting down. and all of like how that was playing out. And like my last, the last day, like the day we found out that like the university, Auburn University was going to shut down like March 13th, right?
也许是因为我住在阿拉巴马州，所以这里看起来有点不同。但是，你知道，去年三月非常生动。去年三月，当，你知道，我记得，你知道，一切都关闭了。以及这一切是如何展开的。就像我的最后一天，就像我们发现大学，奥本大学要关闭的那一天，3月13日，对吧？
That was that Friday. And then that Sunday on the 15th, all staff got an email like, hey, we're going to start doing some remote work. And we're like, whoa, whoa, what's happening?
那是那个星期五。然后那个周日，15号，所有员工都收到了一封电子邮件，说，嘿，我们要开始做一些远程工作了。我们当时想，哇，哇，发生了什么？
And I remember, you know, on the 11th that Wednesday, I was seeing the movie Emma about the Jane Austen novel. And it was, you know, I didn't know it was the last time I'd be sitting in a movie theater for a really long time. And all of a sudden, my phone just starts buzzing and buzzing. I was like, what's going on?
我记得，你知道，在11号那个星期三，我正在看根据简·奥斯汀小说改编的电影《爱玛》。而且，你知道，我不知道那是我很长一段时间以来最后一次坐在电影院里。突然，我的手机开始嗡嗡作响。我当时想，发生了什么？
And the NBA is getting canceled. March Madness is getting canceled. And it was like, what's happening? But man, I have to tell you, April is blurry. April is is gone. Like it's, I remember Easter because we did like a family Zoom Easter. My boyfriend and I and then my two friends that are back in Indiana, we did. We played ticket to ride virtually together one weekend, and that'll be a year ago on this coming
NBA被取消了。疯狂三月被取消了。就像，发生了什么？但伙计，我必须告诉你，四月很模糊。四月消失了。就像，我记得复活节，因为我们做了一个家庭Zoom复活节。我和我的男朋友，还有我在印第安纳州的两个朋友，我们做了。我们一个周末一起虚拟玩了《车票之旅》，那将是去年这个即将到来的
Sunday. So I remember that. But there's like very few events because when you're working from home and you're not, and you're not even leaving your apartment, you know, for anything besides going to the grocery store, it's, it was murky. But when it came back was Memorial Day weekend. Yeah, Memorial Day weekend of last year with not only having a holiday. day and things like that, but then the killing of George Floyd happened. And so that is, like,
周日。所以我记得那个。但事件非常少，因为当你在家工作时，你甚至没有离开你的公寓，你知道，除了去杂货店，它，它是模糊的。但它回来的时候是阵亡将士纪念日周末。是的，去年阵亡将士纪念日周末，不仅有一个假期，
I think a big event for me that kind of like started the H-SAM again of like, okay, we're back. Like, and events started happening. Dr. Yasser, what is the practical application of your work in this area? I mentioned in the intro in looking at Alzheimer's, kind of the opposite where people lose their autobiographical memory. Is this going to help with that? We hope so. And in particular, some of our colleagues have also kind of identified what we think is the opposite scheme, what they call S-dam or severely deficient autobiographical memory. So this is my colleague Brian Levine and his laboratory have identified individuals who have very, very fuzzy records of the past.
还有其他事情，然后乔治·弗洛伊德被杀事件发生了。所以那是，就像，我认为对我来说一个大事件，它有点像重新开始了H-SAM，就像，好吧，我们回来了。就像，事件开始发生了。亚萨博士，你们在这个领域的工作有什么实际应用？我在介绍中提到了研究阿尔茨海默病，这是一种人们失去自传体记忆的相反情况。这会有所帮助吗？我们希望如此。特别是，我们的一些同事也确定了我们认为是相反的方案，他们称之为S-DAM或严重缺陷自传体记忆。所以这是我的同事布莱恩·莱文和他的实验室确定的那些对过去记录非常非常模糊的个体。
Now, they still do okay on other memory tests and okay in other facets of life. and they're not Alzheimer's patients or anything like that, but their record of the past is not as rich as most of us would have. So it seems like there is sort of a continuum or maybe a bell-shaped curve with two extremes here. And understanding the extremes always informs us about the process and the mechanism. When the condition was first identified, Dr. McGaugh, I think is quoted, as saying this might have us, you know, rewrite the textbooks and really rethink the way we think about memory because we've always, you know, grown in the field to think that memory is adaptive because it doesn't store everything.
现在，他们在其他记忆测试和生活的其他方面表现依然良好。他们不是阿尔茨海默病患者或类似情况，但他们对过去的记录并不像我们大多数人那样丰富。因此，这似乎是一个连续体，或者可能是一个带有两个极端的钟形曲线。理解极端情况总是能让我们了解过程和机制。当这种状况首次被发现时，我想麦高夫博士曾说过，这可能会让我们重写教科书，并真正重新思考我们对记忆的看法，因为我们一直以来在这一领域认为记忆是适应性的，因为它不会存储所有东西。
It leaves a lot out and really focuses on things that can be used for generalizable knowledge. And in fact, there are lots of examples about how damaging it would be if we tried to store everything because we would not be able to generalize. However, seeing and the experience of those with age, SAMs suggests otherwise, suggest that maybe we miss something in that original assessment, and that it is possible to generalize flexibly and be able to apply knowledge and have an exceptional track record of the past. So from a fundamental neuroscience perspective alone, it's really informative to try to understand that condition.
它遗漏了很多东西，真正专注于那些可用于概括性知识的事物。事实上，有很多例子表明，如果我们试图存储所有东西，那将是多么具有破坏性，因为我们将无法进行概括。然而，观察那些患有超常自传体记忆（H-SAM）的人的经历则表明并非如此，这暗示我们可能在最初的评估中遗漏了一些东西，即灵活地进行概括、应用知识并拥有卓越的过去记录是有可能的。因此，仅从基础神经科学的角度来看，试图理解这种状况确实很有启发性。
And of course, once you understand the machine and how it works, you could start to understand also how it breaks down. So I do think there's going to be a lot of applicability to conditions where we have memory loss, not just Alzheimer's disease, but a variety of different neuropsychiatric illnesses as well. So Markey, I'm guessing that as a result of your work with Dr. Yass's lab, that you were able to meet other people like yourself with H-SAM. What was that like to finally meet somebody who has a memory like yours? I would say that the first meeting was very dramatic because six,
当然，一旦你了解了机器及其工作原理，你就可以开始了解它是如何发生故障的。所以我确实认为，这对我们出现记忆丧失的状况会有很大的适用性，不仅是阿尔茨海默病，还有各种不同的神经精神疾病。所以Markey，我猜由于你与Yass博士实验室的合作，你能够见到其他像你一样患有H-SAM的人。终于见到一个记忆力和你一样的人是什么感觉？我想说第一次见面非常戏剧化，因为六，
60 Minutes Australia made it very dramatic. But Dr. Yes is like, yeah, I think I've seen this video. But anyway. What did they do? Oh, my gosh. So I met Becky, who is a lovely, lovely woman from Australia, from, I believe, Queensland, Australia, that has H-SAM as well. And 60 Minutes Australia wanted to do a segment.
澳大利亚的《60分钟》节目把它拍得非常戏剧化。但Yes博士说，是的，我想我看过这个视频。但不管怎样。他们做了什么？天哪。所以我见到了Becky，她是一位来自澳大利亚的可爱女士，我相信是来自澳大利亚昆士兰州，她也患有H-SAM。澳大利亚的《60分钟》节目想做一个专题报道。
on her as being at the time at least the only Australian and maybe still the only Australian with H-SAM. And her dream was to meet another person with H-SAM. So they looked at kind of the perspective folks and notice I was the closest one to her age and also a girl. And so, you know, they thought it'd be good for us to meet. So 60 minutes and all their team flew my mom and I out to Los Angeles and we got to meet Becky. And they did this very dramatic like walk-in scene of like me standing in a courtyard and like her walking in like it was the bachelor or something and then also the hilarious part too is like and anyone listening to this who has filmed a TV show before will know this but they had to do that take like 10 times and so you know I met her
关于她是当时（至少是）唯一的澳大利亚人，也许现在仍然是唯一患有H-SAM的澳大利亚人。她的梦想是见到另一个患有H-SAM的人。所以他们查看了潜在的人选，并注意到我是最接近她年龄的人，而且也是个女孩。所以，你知道，他们认为我们见面会很好。于是《60分钟》和他们所有的团队用飞机把我和我妈妈送到了洛杉矶，我们见到了Becky。他们安排了一个非常戏剧化的入场场景，比如我站在庭院里，她走进来，就像《单身汉》节目或者其他什么一样，而且最搞笑的部分是，任何听过这个节目并拍摄过电视节目的人都会知道这一点，他们不得不拍了大约10次那个镜头，所以你知道，我见到她
for the first time once but I had to act as like surprised and shocked and in awe as like I did the first time and you know Becky and I aren't TV actresses here like we're not we're not I didn't get big or anything. So it was just kind of funny as they're like, all right, act surprise again. And we're like, okay. So, you know, it was kind of funny. But Becky and I did get to develop a relationship and become friends.
是第一次，但我必须表现得像第一次那样惊讶、震惊和敬畏。你知道，Becky和我不是电视女演员，我们不是，我没有变得大牌什么的。所以当他们说“好，再表现得惊讶一点”时，这有点好笑。我们说“好吧”。所以，你知道，这有点滑稽。但Becky和我确实建立了一种关系，成为了朋友。
And that was, that was the actual meaningful part. And that was the first time I hadn't met anyone. The second time was when I was doing a segment for Scientific American and they filmed us in New York City when I was a graduate student back. in 2017. And I got to meet Joey and Nicole, who are both East Coasters with H-SAM. And so meeting them was really awesome too. They didn't do the dramatic meet scene. They kind of just had us all like in a, you know, in kind of a panel kind of mode and stuff like that. But it's really cool to meet others with HSAM because you can talk about like similar experiences that you have because of your H-SAM that other
那才是真正有意义的部分。那是我第一次见到其他人。第二次是我为《科学美国人》做专题报道时，2017年我还是研究生，他们在纽约市拍摄了我们。我见到了Joey和Nicole，他们都是患有H-SAM的东海岸人。所以见到他们也真的很棒。他们没有安排那种戏剧性的见面场景。他们只是让我们像在一个小组讨论模式中一样。但见到其他患有H-SAM的人真的很酷，因为你可以谈论一些因为你的H-SAM而拥有的相似经历，而其他人
people may not experience. You can make jokes with them too, you know, date-related jokes that are super fun. And just, again, just relate to, you know, we all have friends that we relate to for certain things, right? Like, if me and a friend are really into at the NFL, you know, we're going to connect over that. But there's only a handful of people in the world that you can connect over this with. And so it's really special when you get to meet. Dr. Yes, where is this research going next? What's the big question you would still like to answer? So there's a few avenues that we're pursuing. One is that we would like to use more sort of validated tests to really fully assess the extent of H-SAM
可能不会有这种经历。你也可以和他们开玩笑，你知道，关于日期的笑话，超级有趣。而且，再次强调，只是产生共鸣，你知道，我们都有朋友，我们在某些事情上与他们产生共鸣，对吧？比如，如果我和一个朋友都非常喜欢NFL，你知道，我们会因此而建立联系。但世界上只有少数人能和你在这方面产生共鸣。所以当你见面时，这真的很特别。Yes博士，这项研究接下来会走向何方？你仍然想回答的重大问题是什么？所以我们正在追求几个方向。一个是，我们希望使用更多经过验证的测试来真正全面评估H-SAM的程度，
and be able to cater to different ranges of experiences and different ages, as Markey said. So we've developed a couple of tools that we're able to use in children and adolescents that are not so time and era sensitive. We've developed another one that is tapping into. different areas of expertise. And we're just in the process of validating those tests and making sure that they are reproducible and reliable and using them on a large enough data set so we can get a better feel for the prevalence of H-SAM.
并能够迎合不同的体验范围和不同的年龄段，正如Markey所说。因此，我们开发了一些工具，可以用于儿童和青少年，这些工具对时间和时代不那么敏感。我们还开发了另一个工具，旨在挖掘不同领域的专业知识。我们正处于验证这些测试的过程中，确保它们是可重复和可靠的，并在足够大的数据集上使用它们，以便我们能更好地了解H-SAM的患病率。
Second, we would like to keep experimenting with the neurobiology and really try to understand how is it that brains might be wired a little bit differently or have developed in a slightly different way to allow for these superior abilities to manifest. and that involves brain imaging studies which we're embarking on. And then the third piece is the genetics and trying to really figure out if there is a heritable pattern, and trying to figure out if there's something about gene environment interactions, perhaps in the earliest ages during childhood and adolescents,
其次，我们希望继续进行神经生物学实验，并真正试图理解大脑是如何以稍微不同的方式连接或发育的，从而使这些卓越的能力得以显现。这涉及我们正在着手进行的脑成像研究。第三部分是遗传学，试图真正弄清楚是否存在一种可遗传的模式，并试图弄清楚基因与环境的相互作用是否存在某种联系，也许是在童年和青春期的最早阶段，
that allow for this to fully kind of come through. So those are, I think, the three areas that we're mostly concerned with right now, And we're expanding to work with some collaborators who really do exceptional work in these areas to have a better handle on it. Last question, to Markey. Are you glad you have this ability or would you give it up? That's a hard question. It's really a hard one. And the answer lies somewhere in the middle.
这使得这种能力能够完全显现出来。所以，我认为这些是我们目前最关心的三个领域。我们正在扩大与一些在这些领域确实做出卓越工作的合作者的合作，以便更好地掌握它。最后一个问题，问Markey。你很高兴拥有这种能力，还是你会放弃它？这是一个很难的问题。这确实是一个难题。答案介于两者之间。
And that's what I've had to come to in the choices I've had to make. So when I found out that I had obsessive compulsive disorder, you know, I had the opportunity start getting treatment, start getting medicated. And when I started getting medicated, my ability to recall as fast and quick and almost even sometimes accurately as I could, started to go away. And so, you know, I had to end up making the choice. Do I want to live with OCD and H-SAM? Or do I want to not really live with a muted version of OCD and a muted version of H-SAM. And I chose living with the muted version because I'm a full functioning human being with dimensions to my wellness and to my life. And I love having H-SAM and the ability
这就是我在必须做出的选择中所达到的结论。所以当我发现我患有强迫症时，你知道，我有机会开始接受治疗，开始服药。当我开始服药时，我那种快速、敏捷，甚至有时准确的记忆能力开始消失。所以，你知道，我最终不得不做出选择。我是想带着强迫症和H-SAM生活？还是想过一种强迫症减弱版和H-SAM减弱版的生活？我选择了过减弱版的生活，因为我是一个功能健全的人，我的健康和生活都有维度。我喜欢拥有H-SAM和这种能力，
to go back in the past and recall and remember and cherish and savor those memories is so important to me. But it can't get in the way of the rest of my life in my future. You know, it's kind of like picking between the past and the future. And it's a hard choice. choice. But, you know, I still have the ability. Could it be, again, more entertaining on TV shows if I stopped my treatment for OCD? Maybe, yeah, but is it worth it? It's not. And so it's kind of hard, but I'm glad I'm at where I'm at now with balance. Thank you both for joining us today. It's been a pleasure talking to you. I really appreciate you taking the time and telling us personal stories. Thank you. Thank you for having us. Thank you so much, Kim.
回到过去，回忆、记住、珍惜和品味那些记忆对我来说非常重要。但它不能妨碍我生活的其余部分和我的未来。你知道，这有点像在过去和未来之间做选择。这是一个艰难的选择。但是，你知道，我仍然拥有这种能力。如果我停止强迫症治疗，在电视节目上会不会更有娱乐性？也许会，是的，但值得吗？不值得。所以这有点难，但我很高兴我现在处于平衡状态。感谢你们今天加入我们。和你们交谈非常愉快。我真的很感谢你们抽出时间并告诉我们个人的故事。谢谢。谢谢你们邀请我们。非常感谢，Kim。
You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology at www. www.combeingof Psychology.org or on Apple, Stitcher, or wherever you get your podcasts. And please leave us a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speakingof psychology at APA.org. That's Speaking of Psychology, all one word, at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman. Our sound editor is Chris Condyion.
你可以在www.speakingofpsychology.org或Apple、Stitcher或任何你获取播客的地方找到《心理学谈话》之前的剧集。请给我们留下评论。如果你对未来的播客有意见或想法，你可以发送电子邮件至speakingofpsychology@apa.org。那是Speaking of Psychology，全部连在一起，@apa.org。《心理学谈话》由Lee Weinerman制作。我们的声音编辑是Chris Condyion。
Thank you for listening for the American Psychological Association. I'm Kim Mills. Do you remember where you were on April 10th, 1999? What day of the week was it? No, you were supposed to answer that. Oh, so sorry. This is my intro. My bad, my bad.
感谢收听美国心理学会的节目。我是Kim Mills。你还记得1999年4月10日你在哪里吗？那天是星期几？不，你应该回答那个问题。哦，真抱歉。这是我的开场白。我的错，我的错。
I was just like, I was four. I thought it was a question too. No, this is the intro. This is the intro. I'm trying to, try to bring people in. All right. Okay, Chris, Chris, never mind all that. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我当时想，我才四岁。我也以为那是一个问题。不，这是开场白。这是开场白。我试图，试图把人们带进来。好吧。好的，Chris，Chris，别管那些了。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。